logé pendant des décennies dans des
conditions déplorables
les pompiers du lamentin ont enfin
n'aurait caserne conçu pour leur mission
et puis avril 18 professionnels et une
soixantaine de volontaires sont basés
ici un chantier de deux millions huit
cent mille euros financé pour moitié par
l'état 30% par la ctm et 20% par le
sdiss aidé par un prêt bancaire vous à
voir que les casernes est au départ
communales elles ont été transférées au
10 mai dans un état de délabrement
avancé
il a fallu procéder d'abord à
l'humanisation de cevital à la
construction de total
c'est un projet auquel nous nous sommes
attelés très tôt un projet certes
ambitieux parce que vous savez qu suivre
12 cases and seul coup c'était un
challenge league bien ça les trois ilets
cette commune compte une caserne honneur
et 3 construction débute bientôt casse
pilote le diamant puis le vauclin
partout la commune doit offrir un
terrain pour l'ensemble des sapeurs
pompiers
chaque chantier de l'île est une urgence
nous avons de beaux soucis au niveau des
casernes du nord comme basse-pointe
marigot l'eau et sept maris ou csa l'ubs
et les endroits sont trop étroits même
pour l'accès des camions et également
pour le personnel trinity insalubre
qu'on redescend un peu plus plus on a
les casernes de cet esprit de ducos
dans le sud on a le marin le marais où
les anges ont de quoi difficultés à
sortir
il ya eu beaucoup de
dad humanisation du centre de secours
mais ce n'est pas suffisant les pompiers
ont besoin de caser en propre qui dit
caserne neuve ne dit pas matériel neuf
en martinique le parc de véhicules est
vieillissant ainsi selon la cgt m les
trois quarts des vs avez threat à
remplacer le matériel d'intervention
souffre aussi du faible au taux de
recouvrement de la dette des communes à
l'égard du sdiss je vais pas cacher que
la situation financière en particulier
elle tend à s'améliorer même si tout
cela reste très fragile
vous savez comme moi même comme dans un
environnement qui est pratiquement
contraints de ce point de vue là et que
ça impose pour nous tous cas aux 10 nous
impose une maîtrise budgétaire de tous
les moments donc que là nous travaillons
à un projet d'établissement qui a comme
leitmotiv de faire en sorte d'optimiser
les moyens d'optimiser les ressources si
de l'avis de tous le climat social est
apaisé après le long mouvement de 2016
le retard accumulé est telle qu'il est
long à rattraper 24 professionnels
viennent d'être recrutés c'est le
premier concours depuis sept ans